hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembers enter the pathway of knowledge
so that the prophecy of the destiny of
the truth of the purpose of reason we
are huh what are you still doing here
what well I think we finished our story
arc when you die so what are you still
doing here
oh no there's much much more you can
still do with us I don't think so we had
a beginning a middle and end it was
totally serviceable anything else would
just be thought no clearly we were just
telling part one of our story
part one yes just like all the other
obviously playing trilogies like
Highlander transformers and of course
Pirates of the Caribbean plus one maybe
another oh I didn't know that but those
were all meant to just be one film until
the studio forced them to turn them into
trilogy but we got so much more money
out of it I already got lip injections
so I can finally smile oh yeah that just
happened we'll get out of here the movie
has enough filler as it is hmm maybe
telling a critic that he's the Messiah
was a bad idea
very think that of themselves anyway
Matrix Reloaded
after the surprise popularity of the
first film and seeing how many people
were constantly paying homage to it
Warner Brothers felt they had a goldmine
on their hands and felt the need to
stretch this out into a trilogy what
followed was an impressive looking
spectacle that needed to throw in more
of what made the first film so popular
including the Bechet more endless
speeches more pointless fight scenes
more self-indulgent dialogue who likes
Shyamalan thinks sounds more epic if you
don't use contractions we do not wish to
start a pet some of you do not Toby did
not know what happened that is of course
your prerogative the meetings over
you know why we are here seriously
writers why are you so afraid of the '
okay dear me just wants to make your
sentences more practical where most
matrix fans would probably cream their
pants for this most of them actually
were disappointed by it because even for
a Matrix movie it connected practically
none of it to a coherent story let's see
if we can make sense to what was
originally trying to be so blatantly
obvious this is the Matrix Reloaded so
the movie starts off by establishing a
subtle atmosphere through buildup and
mystery
Oh what's your house keys you made me
come
sir we have a report of a dominatrix who
somehow blew up a building with a
motorcycle whatever you do don't use
your guns and pray she's not armed with
a helmet she is certain god help us all
my man so finally they explained what's
going on and for just more of this
bullshit
no I love that car oh we see once again
Keanu Reeves portraying Tom who keeps
having a dream about his girlfriend
Trinity smashing into a car funny most
of the women he dates dreams about him
smashing into a car Morpheus became
played by Laurence Fishburne has he had
another bloated talk with a crew member
named Linc Linc yes sir oh I do hope
what only takes a sentence to say goes
on for several minutes given your
situation I can't say I fully understand
your reasons for volunteering to operate
onboard my translation trust me okay
move along some more pieces game meets
up with a bunch of other people who like
to wear shades and dark places as they
pick the safest of meeting grounds the
matrix which I think these films has
then most of the time establishing why
that's not the safest of meeting grounds
but hey they're still also suggests the
worlds can be saved by Hot Topic are you
surprised by anything anymore
speaking of which here come the men in
bland tell you those it's him yeah
anomaly do we proceed yes you still only
human let's do it
it's night it's been 10 minutes and
we're already on our third action scene
but we're trying to top Sin City for
most violence per minute um still want
to show off that I'm awesome the power
of Reeves compels you
okay okay Morpheus you should have seen
where is he know he's doing this
Superman thing call him by Superman you
mean spending a lot of money on a
computer-generated land psychopath who
hurts more people they saves look yeah
that's a fair assessment but don't worry
there's more but loads of money this
movie's budget wants to flaunt like look
at all these effects going into just the
landing of their damn ship
nebuchadnezzar this is ion control
maintain present velocity and standby
Roger that control
where were we you need to go into the
matrix just to push buttons you need to
go on to a computer to simulate going on
a computer why don't you just go on to a
computer so as you can see the
incredibles ion that's been built up in
the past just seems to be a series of
mall bridges that just like the real
Holy Land is dangerous overhyped
underwhelming ly depressing and yet
people will still fight to the fucking
death for it meanwhile Morpheus has to
talk with the Commissioner yeah I'm sure
he has like a different title or
whatever but listen he's the angry
Commissioner I wanted to offer you the
chance to explain your actions I wasn't
aware that my actions required any
explanation you were given a direct
order to return to Zion I don't care
about Oracle's or prophecies or messiahs
I care about one thing I need soldiers
to obey my orders you have no rights
Morpheus what about the rights of that
little girl I'm just trying to figure
out how I went from Titus to this crap
you were great and I know I was great in
that
I stopped see you soon oh gee I forgot
to mention remember how in the first
film Tom and Trinity had no chemistry
whatsoever well in this one they make up
for that not by giving them things in
common or personality traits to work off
of but rather just have the suck face
whenever they have a second alone it's
really awkward it's kind of like when
Michael Jackson kissed Lisa Marie
Presley it's so forced and in-your-face
that I think a school play of two kids
kissing would be more believable tonight
let us honor these men and women let us
remember those that have been lost now I
would like someone else to close this
prayer I give you more some Morpheus
greatest sleeveless brethren and lets
out a speech that's pretty much every
movie speech you've ever heard in every
movie let us be a bird from reddit our
to black sky tonight let us make them
remember this is Zion and we are not
afraid
tonight we done in our Independence Day
and of course to honor the fallen dead
Morpheus mentioned earlier they break
out the rave music and start fucking
like Jackrabbits it's what their
memories would have wanted so nice to
see this apparently religious ceremony
is looking about as close to the imagery
of Hell as you can get of course it
doesn't help that there's even more of
Tom and Trinity making out and it goes
on I'm not kidding here for almost 5
minutes 5 minutes of this did you just
look at it was so production and say
fuck it we can make it even weirder just
add some wet dress mud and back sockets
you're making the leathery stuff look
normal
oh sorry much like the movie it was all
build-up to a disappointing climax bogus
so after Burning Man two point what was
I uh apparently deserves it sleep after
its religious fucking and tries to get
some rest
good night a little do they know that
one other men is about to get infected
by a heavy dose of ham agent Smith
played by Hugo Weaving infects the
real-life brain of the crew member which
even by matrix rules I don't really get
our flesh and blood can be hacked but
that doesn't matter much as Tom is about
to go see the Oracle I can take you to
her but first I must apologize apologize
for what gee I don't know a fight what a
shock
you do everything around here with a
fight I want to see my mother fight I
want to get some sugar fight I want to
fight let's have a philosophical
conversation about what it means to be
human
I have to be sure of what that you are
the one good of just know you do not
really know someone until you fight them
so I should fight whoever I'm dating he
once again meets up with the Oracle on a
park bench why don't you come and have a
sit this time maybe I understand well
suit yourself
I felt like city and just to be clear
that was the comedy portion of the film
folks deciding whether or not he was
going to sit down next I can't discuss
the hilarious ramifications of blinking
too fast they do still blink right Dendi
you already know if I'm going to take it
wouldn't be much of an Oracle abide it
but if you already know how can I make a
choice because you didn't come here to
make the choice you've already made
translation you're a program yep moving
on but something weaving this way comes
as conveyed by these dark crows who are
so over-the-top menacing they should be
carrying signs sake he's bad surprised
to see me
no I don't fully understand how it
happened perhaps some part of you and
printed on to me something overwritten
or copied or maybe it's just lazy YT now
here I stand because of You mr. Anderson
because of you I've changed I'm
unplugged a new man so to speak like you
apparently free they still have a
program my inflections right but if
Christopher Walken can milk it why can't
I there's no escaping reason no denying
purpose because as we both know without
purpose we would not exist Oh
translation I hate you I hate you ah
so it's revenge of the Smiths as a group
of them try to attack top however when
that doesn't work he gets even more and
when that doesn't work Pete gets even
more and when that doesn't work he gets
more and more and more and holy fucking
shit
I should be bored by the fact that this
is the fifth fight scene and we're not
even halfway through the movie yet but
honestly the access is just so batshit
insane it's actually kind of
ridiculously fun
the fact that I've seen dozens of Hugo
Weaving 'he's constantly get punched in
the face like a whack-a-mole it's
fucking hilarious to me I'm not gonna
lie I could watch it for hours just
imagine him saying ow every single time
he smacked OH
all of course we go into videogame land
again when the seriously dated CGI takes
over but even that's kind of funny when
the pile on top of him like an army of
cartoon ads
well they just take on the shape of a
big giant monster while they're at it
wawk wawk mr. Anders
it exam my motive ah come on get out of
there
don't make me raise my voice again
why didn't he do that before
yeah could have saved us six minutes
well I'm off to look silly in Lord of
the read I'm off to look silly in cloud
app now I'm off to look silly and
Captain America I'm off to look silly in
V for Vendetta and I'm off to sound
silly in transformers so out say is it
me or do you smell an unnecessary tool
performance
mr. Alger critic Chuck told please that
was the old me the new me
goes by Schmucker why because I'm such a
cliched character in so easy to make
there's literally a sucker born every
minute
wow you're good Bill Gore's with a name
like Schmucker I have to be good a
special shout out to the people for 30
who actually got that joke
we appreciate your viewership enough
this time what's your plan Vulcan brow
well it's funny you say that we plan to
teach you a valuable lesson for
reviewing these bill you can take the
crap out of me word we're gonna make
philosophical speeches about why you
shouldn't have you constantly there is a
purpose for you
you see if you think about life and life
our hands
ah
fortunately that corn sighs I feel a
little more as another person is our
destiny is not one that can be fertile
unless its truth lies and the purpose
the what's going on here
it's a pretentious blow-off they're
seeing who can make the most nonsense
make sense
our paths cannot be changed or as the
duty of the past to control the future
to control the present to deny who we
are to deny what we are to deny why we
are that my friend is alive so oh my god
you literally blew their ears off
don't ever deny my pretentiousness again
this is not over Malcolm oz our sources
have indicated that the pathway to
knowledge is here what filler plotline
to drag things out oh all right well you
guys continue on your little sigh quiz
I'm just gonna keep doing the repeat all
right I am madly in love with you where
the fuck did that come from
come on Tammy that's like the fifth
massage had the hots for what I'm number
five so they now had to find a powerful
hacker called the key-maker because
sidequest
as I come across a French computer
program who like everyone else in the
movie was the sound of his own fucking
voice we are looking for the key maker
to look for him is to be looking for a
means to do you know the answer to that
question but do you Artie does everybody
have a fucking speech shoved up their
ass this is of course a way of all
things you see there is only one
constant causality oh you shut up exam
how's that woman watch you see I have
sent her a dessert it starts so simply
each line of the program creating a new
faked yeah we're so desperate folks that
we're actually talking about the
philosophical justifications of cake
fucking cage that are they're trying to
fetishize cake but to be fair the line
between the two is pretty blurred in
these films she does not understand why
beneath our poised appearance would you
care to order I'll have a cake where are
you going I drink too much wine I must
take a piece this attic five minutes of
food porn for that now why is a computer
need to pee if you want the key-maker
follow me I'll give you what you want
but you have to give me something what I
want you to kiss me as if you were
kissing her excuse me you love her she
loves you it's all over you both really
uh no offense lady but I've seen boxes
of wet matches they have more of a spark
than they do I want to sample it well
for the good of the mission honey sucks
to be me
come with me I thought I just did so
they find the key-maker but get
intercepted this results in yet again
Marquis info you know I'm just gonna
make the crazy assumptions gonna win
this one again let's see yeah so let's
just see what happens when he tries to
follow Frenchy up he uses his hacking
powers to put him in the mouth meanwhile
Trinity and Morpheus tried to escape
Frenchie so wipe their transparent
minions as well as a slew of agents to
get the key-maker to safety and I'm not
gonna lie this is a really cool scene
like wow this still really fucking holds
up the action isn't just kung fu and it
isn't just computers it's a good mix of
car-chase gunplay superpowers
hand-to-hand car foo and with pretty
much all the important characters making
an appearance well Smith doesn't but I
think he made enough fuckin appearances
don't you
the only problem once again like all of
these movies is how the hell is the
matrix still kept fucking secret after
all this with every single one of these
weird-ass occurrences explained by
natural causes and in other news reports
are flooding in of people jumping on
cars somehow destroying them flying
green albinos who can float through
walls sword fights on top of trucks and
a dozen instances of people to find the
laws of gravity police reports say that
it was the wind but just when it looks
like all hope is lost
Tom literally flies halfway around the
world just in time to grab Morpheus and
the key-maker
all right now this in my opinion is one
of the biggest holes in the move Creek
we have found the pathway of knowledge
Oh can't it - no it can't
it's in the kitchen we'll take the back
way so that Asians won't suspect us too
late for that I'm afraid fuck
no you put us in the mountain yes all
right Crick we need you to fly us
halfway around the world in order to get
us back or we could just use another way
to the kitchen through the office but
there'd be mountains yes I know they'd
be mountains out there but there's still
office in here it's like a idiot Messiah
he flies thousands of miles around the
globe to reach our heroes but all he had
to do was turn the fuck around and go
back the way he came he never closed the
door behind them so it's the exact same
location we'll take in a two minutes ah
so instead of flying around the world we
could take a few steps to the kitchen to
the kitchen yes to the gate this is the
pathway to knowledge yes behind this
door are the answers to all of the
Matrix movies all the answers like why
they're so silly and make no sense every
single one of them let's check it out
that didn't seem right there must have
been a connection issue we must destroy
the power source take again our side
mission you guys go do that while I
finish up the review stop that No well
as you can see our heroes are starting
yet another side mission even though
they just got done with one other
fucking side mission the key-maker talks
about breaking into the secret
headquarters to have Tom meet the
architect the designer of the matrix how
do you know all this
I know because I must know
is my purpose or maybe it's just lazy
writing we have not come here by chance
I do not believe in chance it is our
destiny
I believe this night holds for each and
every one of us the very meaning of our
mine Jesus translation I like talking we
now move it up so tom tells trinity not
to help him in this because he's afraid
his dream will come true and she'll die
but of course when shit goes wrong were
the only one who can possibly save them
woody
Kennedy's I will not stand here and do
nothing I will not wait here to watch
them die I'm sorry I screamed at you
like that
I know I can be really emotional she
breaks in just like we saw in the intro
allowing them to sneak through the door
but the key-maker gets shocked little to
be Rufus
alright oh no I'm really gonna miss
whatever character he was supposed to
have your name will always be remembered
with whatsits and whosits and that guy
Tom enters the door locates the
architect and naturally disposed more
philosophical speeches your life is the
sum of a remainder of an unbalanced
equation inherent to the programming of
the matrix you are the eventualities of
an anomaly which despite my sincerest
efforts I have been unable to eliminate
while it remains a burden assiduously
avoided translation inspected and thus
not beyond a measure of translations you
are undoubtedly gathering the anomaly is
systemic creating do we ever figure out
what the fuck he was saying in the scene
inevitability of it this is the moment
where the writing is literally so
pretentious and trying so hard to sound
important that nobody could understand
what the hell he was saying return to
the source allowing a temporary
dissemination of the code you carry your
five predecessors were by design based
on a similar predication a contingent
affirmation thus creating the otherwise
contradictory systemic anomaly dude is
this gonna be on the test the best I can
understand is that tom is an anomaly of
the matrix that keeps popping up and the
machines can't get rid of but
sounds like he's the sixth version to do
so and this is the sixth time they're
about to destroy Zion so he has a choice
where he can either save all of Zion or
save his dominatrix who's about to die
just like in his dream but OTO right
leads to the source and the salvation of
Zion the door to your left leads back to
the matrix to her and to the end of your
species
our Messiah folks fuck the world I want
some more leather coated moss pussy
that's owning up to my responsibility as
a great leader
what if fucking Jesus came back from the
grave with an excuse like this hello my
followers just the quick hands up you're
all going to die and it is 100% my fault
but I just wanted to give you a quick
clinch of what you're all getting killed
off for bad ass look at dad now I can
get whipped beaten thrown up on a cross
but if you were to ask me to give up
badass that ass is gonna win funny
that's Messiah Twitter all right
hope you're all too pissed and have a
nice death cheese out
so Tom races at the speed of whoa
bringing apparently half the goddamn
city with it
another strange event today as hundreds
of cars were blown across the city in
the middle of the night presumably
killing several citizens and costing
millions in property damage it happens
but it looks like tom is too late as
trinity bites the bullet and dies off
but death is more like a suggestion in
these movies than a final destination
I'm not letting go I can't
oh yeah you sound like it so we use his
kung-fu CPR to bring her back as we see
our mechanical calamari are lining up to
kill everybody off
I am dream theory but nothing dream is
gone from me no life has killed that you
read he's gone okay but Tom makes an
interesting discovery
what the hell
oh wait I think I see where they're
going with this I woke him to weigh now
but I'll tell you in a little bit he
passes out and they find yet another
ship to pick them up but unfortunately
they have an unwelcome visitor on board
wait what's that guy it's kind of hard
to tell upside down maybe if you switch
it wait who was that guy well remember
that crew member smyth infected that was
mostly kept in the shadows and very hard
to see and remember this idea that they
never really explained very well that
now Smith can hack into our own brain
somehow kind of a rocky narrative to
follow in order to play your Ren and
Stimpy sting music / but no game I'll
still act like it's a big deal when I
was younger I actually liked this bill
more than the first one because of the
access and because it was so over the
top
it still had no character and the riding
was laughably full of itself but that's
pretty much I thought the first one
anyway this one at least when
balls-to-the-wall over the top but I
will admit watching it again I do
realize at least the first film for all
its yapping did keep focused on what it
was talking about this one is just all
over the place trailing off into
conversations and fight scenes that have
nothing to do with anything so yeah it
is definitely worth of ridicule that a
gift from those fans unless they're
going where I think they're going with
it and if they are I think they can
actually save a good chunk of the series
with it and that of course is being
hello the pathway is open critic
discover the secret of the Matrix movies
right
black willy wonka you designed the
Matrix movies oh yes I did it in between
making Twizzlers and caramelizing those
they disagree with my views I think I I
think I finally discovered the secret of
the Matrix movies what it's all building
up to and what is that pretty okay the
real world Zion all of that is actually
just another matrix a backup program so
that all the people that think they got
out the matrix actually never did nope
but that's not what is building up to it
all but that would be such an obviously
good twist it would have worked on so
many levels it would have explained why
Tom could destroy the machines at the
end it would have explained why Smith
could infect a human brain it would have
explained why all the people in the
matrix weren't affected by all the
obvious glitches going adjective how
could this not be in it would explain
every single movie mistake the films
I've ever made I agree
but they're sticking to the safer route
he's just Jesus just Jesus well great we
haven't seen that story yet so what's
with all the TVs you're just seeing how
many television sets the movie can suck
on no those are actually my
teleprompters to remind me if i
confusing lines quid pro quo visa vie
the outcome of one anomaly is higher
than my probability of you know screw it
I'm just going to give it to you
straight I was merely commissioned to
make the Matrix movies the real
masterminds are somewhere else if you
want to know the truth don't trust
anyone the ones you think you can trust
have already been taken over who who's
doing this people much
darker ah ah
so critic what did you discover
well I discovered someone else's behind
the matrix movies and I shouldn't trust
any book
you
machines